the cowboys at number 10
they will have potentially shireen their
pick
of all defensive players it's kind of
like having the first overall pick in
the draft if they weren't going to take
anybody on offense now
i don't know that they will go defense
but it's kind of nice to have
their pick of the entire defensive draft
board
yeah mike when you start looking at it
those five quarterbacks can go and then
kyle pick
pitts and then penny sewell who you talk
to today then jamar chase then jaylen
waddle not necessarily in that order
but we could see all those guys go
that's nine guys so then the cowboys
would have their pick of defensive
players it'd almost be like having the
number one pick in the draft
in some respects they need defense mike
they need defense bad we know what they
have on offense they sacrificed that
first round pick
last year defensively to go get cd lamb
i get it they can't afford to do that
this year they were last
in franchise history last year in points
allowed they had never allowed more
points in franchise history than they
did last season they've got to improve
that defense
if they're going to contend and we all
know that they expect to contend because
we hear that repeatedly year after year
after year but
this draft could work out well for them
mike and they have the best uh we'll
find out who the best player on their
board defensively is
if they pick a defensive player all
right cowboys trivia
who is the last defensive player the
cowboys took
first overall who is he in what year go
russell russell maryland what year
russell maryland right
uh right here stumped
pressure's on 92 91
91. that was it remember when we didn't
know what rocket ismail was going to do
and he ended up going to play in the cfl
for the bruce mcnall wayne gretzky team
and john candy was involved in some way
i got to go i got to go
back down that rabbit hole but rocket
ismail went to canada initially all
right
here's jerry jones talking about draft
philosophy for the cowboys this year
will they take a defensive player will
they just primarily focus on
their needs and what are their needs
let's hear some from jerry jones
i think that we've got a good chance to
have a top defensive player the top
or one of the top be there at 10.
i think the real thing to do is uh
don't be don't be stupid
over uh your needs
just just talk don't be ridiculous
well and here here's the reality because
we've got one mock draft that we do at
pft and i'm going to go on record and
say
i didn't do it i farm it out
to somebody who has actually been in a
draft room who actually has put a draft
board together can't say who it is but
that's who i've relied on the past
several years
and i didn't tinker with it at all and
i'll give you a little preview shireen
at number 10 our mark draft which is
going to drop at some point tonight most
likely unless i just procrastinate don't
get it done
does not have the cowboys taken to the
defensive player
it hasn't taken a tackle because that is
a
hey that offensive line is crumbling
before our very eyes
yeah well and that's what bill parcells
always said right you
you build with the lines offensive line
defensive line those are the most
important things that's how you build
the team jerry finally listened to him
and built that offensive line to one of
the best in the nfl but you're right
you look at how many games tyron smith
played last season it was fewer than
half you look at how many games
lyle collins played last year it was
zero you look at
zach martin he he missed a bunch of
games last season so
yes they need those players to stay
healthy and i'm not sure that tyron
smith
can stay healthy i mean he's had back
and neck issues for a long time now and
despite the fact that he's only 30 years
old or won't turn 30 until this year
i just think they have to address that
at some point so if they pull the
trigger on that i'm not going to argue
with that because they do need help
on the offensive line and if that player
is rated ahead of any defensive player
they have on the board
go for it i i love how teams this time
of year will say
they're going to take the best available
player but the reality is
their assessment of the best available
player
is driven by the needs they're trying to
fill period i mean if you have a
starting quarterback
and the best available player truly the
best available player on your board is a
starting quarterback
or a quarterback not a starter but a
rookie you're not going to take them
you're not going to take them
and if you can't find a trade that you
like you're going to take somebody else
period
so your needs do drive your assessment
of who the best available may be
and for the cowboys drafting at number
10
they could have their pick of all
defensive players or they may go
tackle and we'll find out on thursday
night along with the other
31 picks in round one hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports